[Music]
women go crazy for you I saw this
picture of you dressed as a woman I
didn't quite know what was happening but
you do make a very attractive woman
you're quite you're quite stunning
and I was curious was this for what was
this was for charity what was no it was
that's called for Marguerite I didn't
know they had cameras in the room yeah
no it was the San Francisco premiere of
the the diary a teenage girl a movie I
didn't and the first ad on that movie is
cousin wonder let legendary drag queen
on in San Francisco and she was planning
this the premiere at the Castro theater
and she was hosting it with all her drag
queen friends and it was mean it was
just something about the excitement of
getting ready for the premiere and I was
sitting there with my gray suit and they
were talking about their wigs and their
dresses and everything and I just felt
like left out and so I asked I asked
cussin because I just called her cousin
on like can I can i play can I be part
of this and and she said yes and asked
who I wanted to be in and I said Farrah
Fawcett I want you came up with that
right away didn't you obviously yeah I
showed him that it's like a famous photo
of her from the I think it's early 80s
and I have the blonde and the the blonde
hair and the golden dress and you know
yeah when blowing it it's a beautiful
picture on so that's what we went for I
you tell me if we succeed it I thought
she looked absolutely I think you look
very nice
have you ever tried that have you ever
been in drag have I been in drag yeah
giving well first of all there was the
college for a year or so four years in
college
Coe Nina was my name no III think for a
bunch of sketches over the years when
you're in comedy and you've been in
comedy as long as Andy and I have been
dressed as women a thousand times he's
easily a thousand times and I present I
find it well settle down but IIIi don't
want you do it and you're like hey this
is ver how did you feel like physically
did you feel pain or no no I felt right
for the first time in my life I felt
great in here I really loved the
transformation and everything it was
just physically it was shooting Tarzan
was nothing compared to him the pain I
had to endure for I just got those heels
and yeah there's shoes Oh every man
would have to wear high-heeled shoes for
a little while just to learn what women
go through I felt like every sister
hands I couldn't grab anything so I was
walking around the after party like this
no it's it's insane I think every man
should have to wear well you know the
the high heels and the long eels and
their underwear just yeah oh sure
what happened I'd like that
you